en février 1964 la venue des Beatles
fait souffler un vent d'optimisme sur
les États-Unis l'arrivée des Rolling
Stones en juin offre tout un contraste
il se présentait comme l'antithèse de
l'image des Beatles
venaient incendier ta ville
rebelle dangereux drogué et sexy c'était
ça les Stones
alors que le mouvement
[Musique]
hippie s'est des Rolling Stones semble à
contre-courant
ils ne se sont jamais vraiment laissés
emporter par l'idéalisme des années 60
changer les choses en fumant de la Marie
ce n'était pas très réaliste
la vision des stands reflétait donc
mieux la vérité quelques mois à peine
après l'été de l'amour le monde change
d'un seul coup
en 1968 la noirceur des Stones faisait
désormais co à ce qui se passait dans
les rues de Chicago de Paris et de
Londres
le sang coulé dans les rues la
température augmentait très très vite
semblait être venu ce documentaire suit
la trace des Rolling Stones à travers
cette époque turbulente jusqu'au
festival d'altamandes en décembre 1969
le brutal est tragique point final de la
décennie Bosch bien que les Stones d'une
certaine façon le désordre et les chaos
il n'avait aucune idée de ce dans quoi
il s'était embarqué à altomante
il ne s'attendait pas à ce que ça tourne
comme ça
des actes de sauvagerie d'une grande
laideur se sont déroulées sous nos yeux
les Angels étaient abominable
c'était comme une collision de voiture
il y a rien à faire quand on est dedans
les choses allaient de mal empire la
situation était hors de contrôle il
s'agit probablement de la vie pire jour
de
[Musique]
toute ma
nous sommes le 17 octobre 1969 après une
longue période loin de la scène les
Rolling Stones atterrissent à Los
Angeles pour commencer les préparatifs
de la plus grande tournée de leur
carrière
cette série de 16 concerts dans de
grands Arena un peu partout aux
États-Unis est forte attendue par un
public de jeunes admirateurs de plus en
plus nombreux
on avait hâte de voir ce qui allait être
sûrement un grand événement les attentes
étaient très élevées
on voulait entendre ce qu'ils avaient à
dire
les Rolling Stones n'avaient pas joué
aux États-Unis depuis plus de 3 ans
les choses avaient changé radicalement
au cours de cette période alors tournée
antérieure les filles mouillaient
littéralement leurs culottes et
hurlaient comme des données
la prestation durait peut-être 20
minutes avant que la foule de 10000
personnes se ruent vers la scène
affrontait donc un phénomène qui les a
d'abord faite complètement flipper
et auditoires qui restaient assis et qui
voulait les écouter
malgré leur étonnement les Rolling
Stones maintenant présentés comme le
plus grand groupe de rock n' roll au
monde donne une série de concerts qui
entre bientôt dans la légende tout le
monde était en feu avec cette énergie
qui émanait du groupe et celle qui est
mena des femmes
j'allais les voir tous les soirs et
c'était à chaque fois différent
les cancers étaient spectaculaires les
godenaient tout un spectacle
[Musique]
1969 les stands étaient incroyables ils
étaient géniaux ils faisaient tout un
taspage les stands étaient le plus
important groupe à faire de la tournée
les Beatles s'étaient retiré de la scène
Bob Dylan s'était retiré mais les stands
étaient sur la route en 1969 venir aux
États-Unis cette année-là ce n'était pas
de la blague les groupes se retrouvaient
en plein cœur de tout le grammage qui
s'est déroulée alors
les États-Unis étaient dans un état
d'agitation disons en 69 l'été de
l'amour en 67 s'était déjà loin
les choses avaient pris une tournure
plutôt sombre en partie à cause des
manifestations contre la guerre du
Vietnam et de l'assassinat de Martin
Luther King et de Robert Kennedy
l'humeur était donc beaucoup plus morose
cela dit l'optimisme des hippies
perdurer encore un peu
l’année 69 en fait été le point
culminant de ce mouvement sur certains
plans plus que l'année 67 car c'était
l'été de route Stark
tenue au mois d'août 1969 et attirant
près d'un demi million de spectateurs le
festival de Woodstock est un concert
gratuit d'une durée de 4 jours qui
témoigne de la force croissante de la
culture des jeunes en novembre alors que
leur tournée tire à sa femme et Rolling
Stones annonce leur propre festivals
gratuits sur la côte ouest l'emplacement
prévu à l'origine est le parc Golden
Gate de San Francisco mais l'événement
aura finalement lieu sur le terrain de
circuit de cour s’éloignés nommé
altamante
le festival d'atoman se voulait
l'expression de l'optimisme et de la
vigueur de la contre-culture
un événement où toutes les tribus
pourraient se rassembler
quand le concert a été annoncé il
s'agissait en apparence d'une grande
nouvelle et d'une nouvelle très
réjouissante
la mythologie entourant les concerts
gratuits et véritablement à son apogée
en 1969
l'expression concerne gratuit évoque
toutes les valeurs les images et les
idées qui circulaient dans la
contre-culture à l'époque
ça aurait pu être fantastique tout le
monde pensait que ce serait un mini
Woodstock à San Francisco dans le parc
du Gourden gate ce n'est pas ce que ça a
donné
cet événement s'y prometteur va tourner
au désastre et finalement constituée un
point de rupture ou le rêve de
solidarité pacifique de la
contre-culture s'effondre tragiquement
la violence et le chaos dans son témoin
et les Rolling Stones pendant ce concert
révèle une Amérique fort différente de
celle apparemment si calme qu'ils ont
découvertes à leur première visite à
peine plus de 5 ans auparavant le
développement du groupe durant cette
période est toutefois inextricablement
liée à l'évolution des tendances au sein
de la culture des jeunes aux États-Unis
en 1962 les États-Unis sont une nation
dynamisée par une longue période de
croissance économique et de prospérité
la culture de la consommation basse en
plein les progrès technologiques
transforment la vie quotidienne à une
vitesse inouïe bien des gens croient à
vivre le début d'un nouvel âge d'or où
le rêve américain peut de nouveau
s'épanouir
la menace omniprésente d'une guerre
jette pourtant de l'ombre sur cet esprit
de thymisme confiant qui cache
d'ailleurs des tensions sociales
bouillonnantes
les États-Unis étaient à bien des égards
un endroit étrange au début des années
60 sur le plan de la culture populaire
c'était plutôt fade et anodin
par contre en politique on a kénédé et
sa cour surnommé Kamelott qui reflète un
certain optimisme le sentiment d'avoir
rompu avec la génération d'après-guerre
et l'espoir qu'il s'agit du début d'une
vision politique plus jeune plus
énergique
tourner vers l'avenir
tout ça était cependant en venimé dans
une certaine mesure par la guerre froide
la baie des cochons et la situation à
Cuba
près de la moitié de la population des
États-Unis était âgé de moins de 25 ans
et les jeunes avaient l'impression
d'avoir irrité d'un monde plein de
problèmes pour les membres de la
nouvelle génération qui avait grandi
durant la guerre froide sous la menace
de l'anéantissement nucléaire la
prospérité matérielle ne concordait en
rien avec leurs intérêts qui étaient
plutôt le sentiment de communauté le
désir de justice sociale et la
spiritualité le planeur de l'économie en
soi n'allait pas les aider à obtenir ces
choses
en novembre 1963 l'équilibre de la
nation est fracassé par une tragédie
l'assassinat du président John fennedy
qui représente l'optimisme et le
renouvellement aux yeux de bien des gens
l'événement stupéfile la Nation toute
entière mais en particulier les jeunes
qui sont traumatisés par la violence et
le chaos qu'il reflète
dès le début de l'année suivante une
voix d'espoir émanant de rivage lointain
commence toutefois à se faire entendre
l'assassinat de Kennedy alors que la
nation était dans un deuil profond
qu'elle était en état de choc
le groupe est passé à l'émission d'aide
sur Levin et à immédiatement ramené les
sourires sur les visages
ça semble anodin et insignifiant mais
c'était vraiment comme ça c'était de la
médecine ce que les bétons ont fait on
ne pourra jamais trop insister sur
l'importance de leur arrivée
le succès fulgurant de ce quatuores
révolutionnaire ouvre la porte à des
dizaines d'autres groupes britanniques
qui chercheront à percer aux États-Unis
plusieurs d'entre eux viennent également
de Liverpool comme Jerry and the
pacemakers de searchers et Billie jaymer
mais en 1964 un groupe londonien à
l'image et au sont très différents
traverse à son tour l'Atlantique
contrairement à leur compatriote et
Rolling Stones ne font pas dans le petit
missme on avait pas l'impression que
c'était simplement le tout dernier
groupe venu d'Angleterre c'était
l'époque de l'invasion britannique et
chaque semaine il y en avait un nouveau
les seuls chers
étaient totalement différents il
dégageait quelque chose de complètement
différent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
personne d'autre ne faisait de la
musique comme celle des Stones ils
aimaient le blues la musique des noirs
et illimitait mais il limitait très bien
et ils ont su en saisir une partie de
l'essence leur interprétation n'était
pas superficielle
les Rolling Stones composés du chanteur
Mick Jagger des guitaristes qui Pictures
et Brian Jones du bassiste
découvre cependant qu'ils ont un attrait
limité aux États-Unis et leur première
tournée de ce pays s'avère décevante
quand les Rolling Stones sont venus aux
États-Unis pour la première fois en 1964
ils n'ont pas été accueillis avec des
acclamations leur chanson n'était pas
encore diffusées à la radio à Los
Angeles ils sont passés à l'émission de
télévision de Hollywood parlus dont
l'animateur était Dean Martin il a dit
c'est gala vont faire un concours
d'arrachage de cheveux avec les Beatles
les autres invités c'étaient deux
éléphants ce qui vous dit ce que
l'Amérique pensait des Stones à l'époque
et Dean Martin s'est bien moqué de
les Stones avaient joui d'une bonne
publicité préalable ils avaient des
engagements mais les Américains ne
voyaient pas en eux ce qu'ils auraient
aimé voir ce public attendait vraiment
une copie des Beatles et ce n'est pas ce
qu'il a eu
l'ascension au sommet des Rolling Stones
a pourtant été fulgurantes au
Royaume-Uni mais cette informée qu'elle
était 1962 le groupe s'est rapidement
fait un nom dans le circuit blues de
Londres et a fait une entrée remarquée
au palmarès britannique moins d'un an
plus tard
alors que les États-Unis souhaitent
l'arrivée de nouveaux Beatles l'attrait
des Rolling Stones dans leur patrie
s'est bâti sur une image tout à fait
opposée à celle de leur confrères de
Liverpool leur producteurs Angelo
Goldman Fastone soigneusement cette
image les Rolling Stones ne sourit
jamais sur leurs photos ils répondent
avec indifférence en entrevue dès le
début les Stones sont présentés comme
des rebelles
autant que d'insolence ça a placé les
Rolling Stones du côté des jeunes en
opposition à l'ordre établi ils ont
probablement été le premier groupe
anti-estable
ils avaient une attitude banque sauf
qu'on n'utilisait pas le mot panc à
l'époque
on disait que c'était de la racaille des
Russes ça s'applique aussi aux Beatles
et peut-être à John Lenny en particulier
l'instinct de Brian Epstein lui
commandait de baisser ça d'un ton de
leur faire porter des complets de les
rendre aussi respectables que possible
sans perdre complètement leur côté
frondeur
l'instinct d'autres dames lui dictait
exactement le contraire
un dieu avait une vision claire pour le
groupe il voulait en faire un gang qui
serait l'opposé de celui des Beatles je
pense que les stands ont compris la
vision d'andro il leur a dit vous savez
vous seriez pas soyez un peu revêche
vous n'avez pas à
répondre qu'il ne répondent pas
autrement qu'ils disent juste oui ou non
qu'il s'exprime par des monocyabes il va
voir l'air cool
[Musique]
ça permettait une grande individualité
au sein du groupe combiné à
l'ingéniosité de Jagger qui la manifesté
dès le départ
au détachement cool qui est friture
et au charisme extraordinaire de Brian
Jones
qui était à cette époque là comme
personne d'autre qu'on n'ait jamais vu
l'image des Rolling Stones complémente
parfaitement leur musique
après quelques 45 tours qui connaissent
un succès mineur il s'impose enfin avec
note fadeway digne représentant de leur
mélange unique de blues et de rock'n
roll le son qui a fait sensation sur le
circuit des clubs les voit maintenant
s'élever au sommet des palmarès
britanniques
[Musique]
britannique a émergé
est né dans les clubs de jazz c'était
considéré comme un peu populiste et par
conséquent mal jugé la musique des
groupes de musique comme les Beatles
mais aussi Billie jaymer et Freddy and
The Dreamers était axé sur la mélodie
les Stones dégagaient quelque chose de
sombre à l'américaine il ne s'inspirait
pas de Liverpool mais bien de l'autre
côté de l'océan des États-Unis de
Chicago et des autres grandes villes
leur son était donc vraiment original il
ne se faisait absolument rien du genre
en Grande-Bretagne
[Musique]
la musique des Stones était basée sur
l'ambiance c'est le rythme qui
accrochait l'auditeur alors que chez les
Beatles c'était les yéyé et les
harmonies ce qui n'intéressait pas
vraiment les Stones notre felloway a
vraiment cristallisé le rapproche
[Musique]
ment blues et ils avaient bien sûr en
Jagger un monorganisme ce qui est
rapprochait leur musique de ses racines
noires pour se faire aussi blanc que
possible
sont venus remettre l'influence noire
dans le rock n' roll même si c'était de
jeunes anglais blancs de la banlieue de
classe moyenne
ça a déclenché une chaîne d'événements
qui ont fait que les journaux nationaux
se sont mis à parler des Stones c'est la
version sombre des Beatles il ne se lave
pas et ce genre de choses tout ça c'est
grâce à notre fairway les Stones nous
invitaient à les suivre dans un voyage
rythmique sans que personne ne sache où
ça allait se terminer
en octobre 1964 les Rolling Stones
seront de nouveau aux États-Unis
ayant maintenant placé quelques succès
au palmarès et fort de leur réputation
grandissante auprès du public jeunesse
il décroche une invitation au El solven
show l'émission qui a contribué à lancer
les Beatles à l'échelle nationale au
début de l'année dès l'entrée à l'écran
du groupe le fossé générationnel qu'il a
ouvert dans son pays d'origine se creuse
davantage
la présentation des Stones à l'émission
d'aide Sullivan a fait les grands titres
tout le monde décrié le fait que Mick
Jagger portait un pull durant sa
prestation
personne ne faisait ça Waits
[Musique]
en scène comme s'il se trouvait dans un
club
il suffisait de le voir ne serait-ce
qu'une seconde pour se rendre compte
qu'il dépasse les bornes et de façon
totalement dévergantée
avec une sorte d'accent noir américain
c'était très sexuel
les Beatles étaient désormais perçus
comme un phénomène passager et
inoffensif par les parents on donnait de
petites tapes sur la tête ce qui aimait
les Beatles comme un enfant
on ne faisait pas ça au fond de
distances aux États-Unis les gens plus
âgés ont réagi avec un désarroi total
sans vraiment comprendre pourquoi mais
instinctivement ils avaient tout à fait
raison
c'est britanniques étaient venus ici
pour remplacer le show business
américain démodé et c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait adieu tout est field
sa présageait qu'on a ensuite appelé le
fossé des générations quand la
population adulte américaine c'est
vraiment sentie menacée et intimidé par
ses propres enfants
[Musique]
ces enfants sont manifestement
impressionnés par ce qu'ils voient sur
la scène d'aide sur leven cette fois-ci
la prestation du groupe est présentée
directement dans les foyers de tout le
pays les Rolling Stones sont
instantanément élevés au sommet du monde
de la musique la taille de leurs
auditoires augmente d'un coup ce qui est
intensifie l'atmosphère frénétique et
indiscipliné de leur concert plus que
quiconque parmi leur contemporains les
Rolling Stones inspirent le chaos il y
avait souvent des émeutes mais je crois
que les fans essayaient simplement de se
rapprocher d'eux mais réussissez en
général à maîtriser la situation quand
on sentait que le public allait se
précipiter sur scène on courait vers les
loges et on fermait tout la sécurité
n'était pas aussi rigoureuse
qu'aujourd'hui mais les portes
suffisaient à empêcher les jeunes de
passer c'était quand même effrayant
beaucoup plus de garçons que les Beatles
suscitaient les hurlements des filles
les Stones invité les garçons à
participer eux aussi les Rolling St
faisait un peu plus macho que les
Beatles à cette époque
que ce soit pour le rythme ou le LUC
rebelle il y avait des jeunes hommes au
concert des Stones à Paris et Hollande
entre autres il y a eu de sérieuses
émeutes des émeutes
du rock n' roll il démolissait les
stands et se battait avec la police ce
n'était pas seulement le fait que ces
jeunes cherchaient la bagarre les médias
dans une large mesure ont souvent
encouragé les spéculations quand est-ce
qu'il se passerait au concert
les gens de la sécurité ne savaient pas
à quoi s'attendre
en ville et qui va y avoir une émeute
vous vous préparez à cette éventualité
au cas où la sécurité dans l'auditoire
était un énorme problème qui a
finalement connu son à dire à altamante
les désordres de ce genre à l'étranger
ne suffisent toutefois pas à freiner
l'optimisme de la Grande-Bretagne
en 1964 on assiste à une véritable
révolution culturelle et artistique un
changement de direction politique à la
fin de l'année donne un nouveau
sentiment de vitalité et d'optimisme à
la nation la jeunesse est maintenant aux
commandes et la capitale du pays Londres
devient un foyer de créativité et
d'innovation
tous les regards se sont tournés vers la
Grande-Bretagne et en particulier vers
Londres les cinéastes et le monde de la
mode en particulier ont soudainement été
attirés vers Londres qu'il considérait
dès lors comme une ville de culture
ça changeait complètement l'idée qu'on
se faisait anciennement de la
Grande-Bretagne celle d'un pays
archaïque presque militariste avec un
ordre historiquement établi symbolisé
par la reine et la famille royale nous
avions désormais de nouveaux
aristocrates qui provenaient des grands
inférieurs c'était John Lee Christie
Mick Jagger Ringo star Michael Terence
tempe tout le monde voulait gravité vers
Londres en 1964 65 c'était la ville où
les choses bougeaient le plus sur terre
la situation est très différente aux
États-Unis bien que l'arrivée des
groupes britanniques est dynamiser la
jeunesse et révolutionner l'industrie du
divertissement l'ombre d'un conflits
violents plane sur la nation
pendant sa présidence John fennedy avait
envoyé un certain nombre de conseillers
militaires au Vietnam afin d'aider le
gouvernement du sud du pays a repoussé
une insurrection communiste soutenue par
le nord
au lieu de poursuivre cette politique
d'engagement limitée son successeur
Lindon big Johnson intensifie le conflit
et engage les forces de son pays dans
une guerre terrestre
en 1965 des milliers de jeunes hommes
sont appelés au service militaire et
envoyés au Vietnam du coup le président
Johnson devient l'ennemi de cette
nouvelle jeunesse qui prend de plus en
plus d'importance
[Musique]
de fin de Demba
le conflit au Vietnam a assurément
contribué plus que tout autre facteur à
politiser le fossé des générations si
Johnson a intensifié à ce moment-là
c'est parce qu'il a fait la terrible
erreur de croire que la situation en
Asie du Sud-Est était une répétition de
celle de l'Europe en 1938 on nous
rappelait encore et encore qu'il ne
fallait jamais refaire l'erreur de Never
Chamberlain à Munich
ces deux situations n'avaient rien en
commun mais c'est malheureusement devenu
une excuse pour envoyer 500 000 soldats
américains au Vietnam lutter pour une
cause complètement désespérée
la conscription qui rendait cette guerre
possible était une mesure incroyablement
impopulaire il y avait aux États-Unis 90
millions de jeunes de moins de 25 ans
dont beaucoup connaissaient des gens qui
avaient été appelés ou qui servaient
dans l'armée et dans plusieurs se
faisaient tuer la guerre était donc
extrêmement controversé autre fait
important les jeunes avaient désormais
aussi tendance à remettre en question la
véracité des explications qu'on leur
donnait sur la guerre sur ses origines
et sur son évolution c'était beaucoup
plus qu'une question politique c'était
une question de confiance
l'application militaire au Vietnam prend
rapidement de l'ampleur mais des
manifestations éclatent dans tout le
pays les jeunes se joignent aux
militants pacifistes pour organiser des
défilés de grands envergure dans les
établissements universitaires la voie
des étudiants s'élève de plus en plus en
opposition à la guerre les jeunes sont
maintenant activement engagés dans un
conflit avec leurs aînés qu'il considère
comme des bellicistes violents et cette
affrontement se déroule au rythme du
rock la bande sonore de l'époque
quand les gens se sont mis à protester
contre la guerre et pour les droits
civiques
la rébellion dans la reine culturelle a
aussi adopté cette tendance
le côté revêche des Rolling Stones
un soudain à qui un aspect politique
le fossé des générations la règle de ne
pas faire confiance au plus de 30 ans et
toutes les idées de la sorte se sont
politisés
ce n'était pas comme Marlon Brando à qui
on demande contre quoi il se rebelle et
qui répand qu'est-ce que tu proposes
cette génération avait des tas de choses
contre lesquelles se rebeller elle était
1965 le président Johnson annonce qu'il
double le nombre de jeunes hommes
appelés au service actifs et des émeutes
raciales éclatent dans le quartier de
watts à Los Angeles
c'est dans ce contexte que les Rolling
Stones lancent I can get now
satisfaction qui saisit parfaitement
l'esprit de leur génération
même si les Stones ne sont rendaient pas
compte à l'époque c'était la culmination
de tous leur travail jusque là
c'est incarnait leur attitude et révéler
ce qui les animait
on a qu'à écouter ce rythme c'est
presque une marche militaire avec son
rythme battant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était la marche de la jeunesse de la
jeune génération
si on ajoute à ça la teneur du texte je
ne trouve jamais satisfaction les Stones
avec ce morceau en particulier
se faisait allaiter 65 les
portes-paroles de toutes les aspirations
des jeunes
est devenu une sorte d'hymne pour cette
génération c'est une performance
incroyable non seulement y a-t-il ce
riff classique de guitare mais aussi
l'interprétation de Jagger quand il
arrive au dernier couplet I'm riding
[Musique]
est vraiment sous-estimé en tant que
chanteur mais quand on isole sa piste
vocale on remarque à quel point il
s'investit dans son interprétation
il y a bien une raison pour laquelle
cette chanson s'infiltre à jamais dans
la mémoire dès la seconde où on l'entend
se mécontentement des jeunes face à la
culture dominante était très présent à
l'époque et les stands lui ont donné une
voix
les Rolling Stones poursuivent leur
développement musical et continue
d'aborder des thèmes à résonance sociale
dans leur 45 tours suivants s'attaquant
au côté caché de la culture britannique
pendant ce temps aux États-Unis une
nouvelle ère débute une ère qui aura une
incidence énorme sur les Stones et tout
leur contemporains dans la lointaine San
Francisco il s'est développé depuis les
années 1950 un milieu artistique
culturel et spirituel fort dynamique axé
sur l'exploration musicale l'usage de
drogue psychédélique et de mode de vie
alternatif ce mouvement va bientôt
changer le monde
San Francisco est un véritable foyer
d'accueil pour les marginaux mécontents
depuis que l'émissionnaire catholique
ils sont arrivés au 18e siècle
les radicaux les rebelles et les
non-conformistes y ont toujours été bien
accueillis
la Ville a donc attiré les libres
penseurs des abusés après la guerre dans
les années 50 ceux pour qui il était
évident que leurs parents ne les
comprenaient pas
l'écrivain Jackie là
il a battu un roman épique sur la route
où il compte l'histoire de deux de ces
personnages qui traversent le pays à
destination de San Francisco
sur la route a officialisé le statut de
San Francisco en tant que capitale de la
libre pensée
le principal événement déclencheur de ce
genre d'activité a été à mon avis
l'arrivée des écrivains beats comme Jack
Kerouac et Alan Ginsberg
peu de temps après sont apparus des
figures comme kizi
dix ans plus jeune que les auteurs de la
génération bits le romancier de renom
Ken kizi popularise une nouvelle drogue
dans la communauté bohémienne de San
Francisco le LSD c'est hallucinogène
jouera un rôle crucial dans la scène
culturelle émergente
en tant qu'auteur de vol au-dessus de
nid de coco il avait découvert les
drogues à lucinogènes quelques années
plus tôt en participant à un programme
expérimental du gouvernement
il est ensuite devenu le lien finalement
entre la génération beat dalen kingsberg
et
le nouveau mouvement hippique est apparu
au milieu des années 60
c'est donc une figure centrale de tout
ce milieu
des événements multimédias ou le LSD
circulait librement et généreusement
et dont les greatford dead étaient
l'orchestre en résidence
les greatford ils se sont donc intégrés
à ce milieu en tant que groupe attitré
ce n'était pas vraiment des concerts
mais les greatford dead étaient présents
il ne joue même pas tout le temps elles
étaient parfois trop défoncées pour
jouer de toute façon personne n'allait
là pour les écouter ça leur a donné une
occasion fantastique celle de développer
leur musique comme bon leur semblait
au début de 1966 cette ramification
musicale des soirées de LSD commencent à
prendre son élan sur le circuit des
clubs locaux aux côtés
on retrouve des groupes comme Jefferson
Airplane et big brothers
une nouvelle culture musicale voit le
jour dans des salles de spectacle comme
le film mort et level & Bar room loin
des mains contrôlantes de l'industrie
commerciale du divertissement
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas de projecteur dirigé
vers les artistes il y avait des
projections qui couvraient le mur du
fond et celui de côté comme ce n'était
pas une science exacte ça couvrait aussi
des parties du sol et des gens
s'assoyaient dedans
c'est un énorme amalgame de couleur
mouvante projetée au mur avec des
boucles de films le groupe n'était pas
mis en valeur et la scène était très
basse à 30 ou 45 cm du sol et la foule
dansait sur la musique elle ne restait
pas assise là à regarder l'artiste comme
un concert habituel
cette sous-culture qui naît dans les
clubs se répand rapidement dans les
différents quartiers et espaces publics
de la ville avec son épicentre dans le
quartier de étagebury
on organise bientôt des conseils
gratuits ou les greatfield Dead et
d'autres groupes jouent devant de
grandes foules dans les rues où les
parcs locaux
à la fin de 1966 le mouvement hippie a
indubitablement pris son envol
ce qui se passe à San Francisco découle
d'une impulsion très démocratique ce
n'est pas commercial il y a des concerts
gratuits
les drogues sont aussi d'une énorme
importance le LSD est toujours légal en
66 ne l'oublions pas
ça devient un outil de libération
soudain la drogue ne sert plus seulement
à s'éclater la tête mais bien à
s'élargir l'esprit
ça va de père je crois avec l'impulsion
démocratique l'amour la paix et les
notions pseudo-politiques et
philosophiques de ce genre qui
sous-tendent le mouvement hippie
si les concepts d'amour et de paix sont
au cœur de cette nouvelle sous-culture à
San Francisco on voit souvent aussi lors
des concerts gratuits un groupe de
non-conformiste un peu moins pacifiste
se mêler aux hippies
un club de motards californien souhaite
aussi vivre uniquement en fonction de
leur propre code présent dans tous les
cas considéré par les autorités comme
une bande criminelle violente ils ont
dès le début établi des liens avec
inkizi et la contre-culture naissante
et les a bourrés de LSD ils ont connu sa
bande de joyeux farceurs les Mary
Pranksters
S sont très vite devenus des habitués
des spectacles des greatford Dead et le
reste de l'auditoire c'est peu a peu
habitué à leur présence ils peuvent être
très servibles ils allaient parfois les
enfants perdus à retrouver leurs parents
ce n'était donc pas inhabituel de les
voir certaines de ces événements
la contre-culture et les Angels étaient
des compagnons de lit somme toute
convenables compte tenu de leur amour
commun du sexe de la drogue et du rock
n' roll ils vivaient vite en marge de la
société
c'est association entre la rébellion et
les hommes à moto remonta Marlon Brando
dans l'équipe est sauvage
sur leur moto ils incarnaient la liberté
en parcourant les autoroutes de long
large c'était comme sur la route sauf
qu'il roulait sur des chevaux de fer il
devait quand même y avoir une certaine
méfiance entre ces deux groupes les
anges menaient une vie différente il ne
souscrivait pas aux notions d'amour et
de paix
pendant plus d'un an la nouvelle
contre-culture californienne a pu se
développer de façon spontanée en
recevant très peu d'attention des médias
pousse cela change en 1967 avec la tenue
d'un concert gratuit beaucoup plus
important au parc du Golden Gate le
Human behin après quelques discours de
personnalité imminente comme Timothée
les principaux nouveaux groupes de la
scène locale se donnent par prestation
parce que c'était le premier du genre on
n'avait jamais vu un tel rassemblement
de membres de la contre-culture avant ce
jour-là
cet exemple c'est donc avéré extrêmement
important
ça semblait fait pour la télévision
c'était une sorte de signal aux médias
nationaux comme quoi il se passait
quelque chose d'intéressant dans la
culture des jeunes à San Francisco les
gens sur scène qui s'adressaient à la
foule était aussi fait pour la
télévision
Timothy leey et Harlem Ginsberg portait
ce genre de longues torches fluide lui
répondait son message sur les bienfaits
des drogues psychédéliques
[Musique]
je ne crois pas qu'on est beaucoup parlé
de ce qui se déroulait à San Francisco
tout au long de l'année 1966
mais avec le Human bein en janvier 67 ça
a tout simplement explosé
et c'est instantanément créé une
mythologie autour de ça
le journaliste de la télé américaine et
il a capté des bêtises à propos des
hippies il semble se prendre pour des
saints ce faisant il a livré un message
codé aux jeunes de partout
que ce n'était pas aussi répressif à San
Francisco pas aussi gris qu'il y avait
de l'espoir qu'on pouvait y aller se
laisser pousser les cheveux et vivre
différemment
les jeunes de partout
osé vers le
le cartilage en quête de
l'influence de San Francisco commence
bientôt à se faire sentir en
Grande-Bretagne les idées et les modes
de la contre-culture américaine
traversent l'Atlantique et les musiciens
en tournée comme les Rolling Stones et
les Beatles sont initiés aux
hallucinogènes par leurs homologues
américaines la nouvelle drogue à la mode
le LSD suscite beaucoup de discussions
mais aussi la crainte que les jeunes
deviennent incontrôlable à peine deux
ans auparavant le gouvernement du
premier ministre Harrod Wilson chantait
les louanges des Beatles et de la
nouvelle culture des jeunes si la
clémence a jusqu'ici prévalu à l'égard
des consommateurs de drogue une réaction
brutale se prépare maintenant la police
effectue plusieurs descentes en février
1967 elle arrive en force au domicile du
guitariste des Rolling Stones kit
Witcher
de plus en plus à la désobéissance les
stables qui n'aimaient pas du tout ça
s'est mis à porter une plus grande
attention à ce que disait les artistes
les Stones étaient vraiment des
candidats idéaux pour les descentes à
l'époque quand la police a commencé à
sévir en février 1967 les Stones étaient
les hommes à abattre
la police a été informée par le tabloïde
new of the World qui se consommait de la
drogue à une fête de kit Witcher à West
withoring dans le sexe
c'était un dimanche soir de février
tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé c'est de la
cendre d'une cigarette de marijuana dans
un cendrier et quelques amphétamines
délivrés sur ordonnance si je ne m'abuse
à la suite de cette descente Jagger a
été condamné à trois mois de prison pour
les pilules et kit reachers a pris 12
mois pour avoir permis que sa maison
servent à cette abjecte consommation de
drogue
personnellement c'est ma bouleversé ça
m'a vraiment choquée on nous a tous
demandé d'être très discret de ne pas
parler aux médias
nous avions reçu du bureau des stands
l'instruction générale de ne rien faire
qui pourrait exacerber cette situation
déjà grave
nous étions tous complètement désemparés
angoissé et inquiets et
inquiet pour eux
bien que ces arrestations consolides la
réputation d'insoumis des Rolling Stones
elle met aussi le groupe sur la touche
durant une bonne partie de cette année
pivot pour le mouvement contre culturel
en attendant leur procès les Stones
effectuent une tournée européenne leur
dernière série de spectacles avant plus
de deux ans Brian Jones est à son tour
la cible de descente de police au mois
de mai et doit lui aussi faire face au
tribunaux pour possession de drogue sur
la côte ouest des États-Unis par contre
l'influence de la contre-culture s'étend
sans entrave le mois de juin donne lieu
au premier grand festival pop à montury
une ville côtière se trouvant à 160 km
au sud de San Francisco ce festival va
s'avérer crucial pour le retentissement
des groupes de raitagebury
à San Francisco tout le monde était très
excité on sentait bien que c'était le
début de la prochaine vague même ceux
dont on n'avait jamais entendu parler
c'était l'occasion de les entendre
descendre à menthuay et passer trois
jours à tous les voir
une transition au Siècle importante le
catalyseur d'un énorme changement
consécutifs au top 10 des associations
malgré leur présence à la fin du
week-end tout le monde ne parlait plus
que de Jimi Hendrix de professionnelle
le monde entier avait fait un tour
complet en trois jours
a été le premier des festivals de
musique pop l'ambiance y était agréable
il y avait beaucoup d'optimisme dans
l'air en plus de l'odeur de la marijuana
et pour moi qui est assisté à ce
festival le point culminant en a été la
prestation de Janis Joplin j'avais déjà
vu Hendrix et les goûts je savais à quel
point ils étaient bons ils étaient venus
en avion avec Hendrix mais quand Janis
chope est entré en scène et a ouvert la
bouche ça m'a fait reculer je n'avais
jamais entendu une femme chantée comme
ça de ma vie
[Musique]
tout le monde était là c'est direct
l'argent de presse des Beatles qui a mis
sur pied le festival alors il y avait
beaucoup de monde qui a pu la voir faire
sensation elle a été excellente ce soir
là
ce sont des trucs une ville américaine
semi-provinciale de taille relativement
petite San Francisco défiait tout à coup
Los Angeles
elle a été la capitale du cinéma et de
la musique populaire sur la côte ouest
tout se passait à elle et San Francisco
ne jouait pas un grand rôle là-dedans
mais les greatford dad étaient de San
Francisco Janis joplan était de San
Francisco cet été là la ville de San
Francisco est devenue un centre de la
musique populaire parce qu'il n'avait
jamais été auparavant
l'un des Rolling Stones est présent à ce
festival historique
il s'agit de Brian Jones toujours dans
l'attente de 60 ans il est venu en
Californie voir de ses propres yeux les
fruits de la nouvelle contre-culture
la présence de Brian Jones qui a été vu
avec Nico dans l'audioir du festival
montre hip-hop ça représentait beaucoup
pour le mouvement
c'était comme si la royauté du rock
britannique venait donner sa bénédiction
au festival
les Stones y étaient donc représentés
c'était la
fondation de
ce qui les mènerait à altermont
ils se sentait un peu à l'écart de ce
mouvement marginal branché quand il
voulait vraiment faire partie
jungle en particulier
souhaité ça pour le groupe
[Musique]
ignée
à la contre-culture sont manifestes
musicales définitif dans un élan créatif
remarquable les Beatles lancent l'album
Serge in Peppers lonely heart Club Band
et le 45 tours all you need is love
démontrant qu'ils ont mieux que
quiconque saisie l'esprit de l'été de
l'amour
l'année 1967 a vraiment appartenu au
Beatles il se passait beaucoup de choses
sur la côte ouest mais engue Is Love est
arrivé vraiment à point l'été de l'amour
comme toutes les plus belles fleurs est
mort après quelques mois mais orgueu
this love a été la chanson qui
symbolisait tout ça à elle seule ils ont
aussi produit solgène Peppers pour le
marché des albums que les critiques du
Time sont qualifiées d'oeuvre d'art en
bonne et due forme ce n'était pas de la
musique pop mais de l'art dans toute ma
carrière à suivre la musique soit à 50
ou 60 ans il n'y a jamais eu quoi que ce
soit d'autre qui ressemble à ça je ne
Peppers ni avant ni depuis
c'était ahurissant ça vraiment épaté
tout le monde chacun y trouvait de quoi
aimer c'était très puissant comme
musique
[Musique]
font appel avec succès de leur
condamnation et redeviennent des hommes
libres déterminés à rattraper les
Beatles les Rolling Stones se réunissent
rapidement afin de pondre leur propre
contribution à l'été de l'amour le 45
tours où I Love You et l'album qui suit
à l'automne le trait décrié d'un
satanique ma justice request offre
cependant une vision moins optimiste de
la situation en opposition à l'humeur
utopique qui caractérise l'époque
et le peace and love semble peut-être un
conciliable mais Jagger et riches
étaient quand même présent lors de
l'enregistrement de all you need is love
en fait leur 45 tours suivants où il
Love You est un chef-d'œuvre à mon avis
les Rolling Stones Jagger et Richards en
particulier était dans la ligne de mire
à ce moment-là
[Musique]
a donc un certain tranchant car ils sont
devenus des cibles des victimes
[Musique]
ça ne ressemblait en rien à all you need
is love c'était sardonique et teinté
d'ironie ce n'était pas inclusif
optimiste enjoué amusant et universel
les Stones ne jouait donc pas vraiment
le jeu les Stones est insensible à tout
ça il ne se sont jamais vraiment laissés
emporter par l'idéalisme des années 60
c'était des dures ça tient en partie du
fait qu'il venait de Londres c'était des
enfants de la ville
le retour à la terre les fleurs dans les
cheveux et tout ce genre de truc ça ne
marchait pas vraiment pour eux ils ne
croyaient pas qu'elle est au parc avec
des amis pour agiter un drapeau
suffirait à convaincre qui que ce soit
d'abandonner quelque chose d'important
ils avaient bien compris que ça
n'arriverait jamais
la réticence des Rolling Stones à se
laisser emporter par l'optimisme ambiant
elle légitimée par certains événements
troublants qui se produisent au cours de
cet été de l'amour 10
000 manifestants pour la paix son
violemment réprimé par la police lors
d'une manifestation à Los Angeles en
le mois suivant des émeutes raciales
éclatent à des trois faisant des
dizaines de morts et des centaines de
blessés alors même que les chantres de
l'été de l'amour pourraient leur vision
d'un nouveau monde les problèmes se
multiplient
ce n'est pas parce qu'on prend une
pilule un jour que tout ça disparaît
changer les choses en fumant de la Marie
ce n'était pas très réaliste
et tout le monde a vite compris à quel
point c'était utopique
l'émergence de la contre-culture s'est
produite exactement au même moment où le
ghetto noir s'est soulevé en force à
Détroit et à beaucoup d'autres endroits
ces deux mouvements ont coïncidé sans
être réellement liés
mais conjointement il donnait
l'impression que tout changeait et que
les bases de la société étaient assiégés
comme jamais auparavant
les émeutes et les ghettos noirs
constituaient assurément les forces les
plus déstabilisantes au pays et celles
qui terrifiait le plus les blancs plus
encore que les rockeurs aux cheveux
longs manifestement
des temples difficiles s'annonce donc
dès le début de 1968 la confiance des
jeunes envers les autorités ça fait
encore plus la victoire au Vietnam a
toujours été présentée comme une
certitude
l'aboutissement inévitable d'une juste
croisade mais les reportages diffusés à
la télévision pendant l'offensive du
tête offre aux Américains une image très
différente de cette guerre lointaine
le général qui commandait l'armée
américaine au Vietnam est rentré aux
États-Unis à l'automne 1967
il a alors déclaré que nous étions en
train de gagner la guerre qu'il n'y
avait pas de quoi s'inquiéter que nous
allions atteindre un tournant et bien
sûr
qu'il y avait de la lumière au bout du
tunnel
à la fin de janvier 1968 toutes les
grandes villes du Sud Vietnam et tous
les grands avant-postes militaires
importants ont été pris d'assaut
simultanément à l'occasion de la fête du
tête
il y avait des Vietnamiens qui
attaquaient l'ambassade américaine de
l'intérieur dans certains qui avaient
travaillé
ces images d'assaillants à l'intérieur
de l'enceinte de l'ambassade et du chaos
généralisé dans le pays
ont eu un effet très dramatique et
immédiat
il est évident qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment de lumière au bout du tunnel
c'était un mirage que le gouvernement
vendait au peuple américain afin de
justifier l'envoi de ses fils au Vietnam
pour cette guerre
une fois que les gens ont pris
conscience de ce qui se passait là-bas
le vent a commencé à tourner
je ne sais pas fait sans résistance mon
pays à tort ou a raison on entendait ça
tout le temps à l'époque
même si la guerre au Vietnam était
injustifiable il fallait l'appuyer les
jeunes ceux qui étaient censés aller au
combat se disaient plutôt non je ne vois
pas comme ça la bataille était engagée
cette bataille ne se déroule cependant
pas uniquement sur le territoire
américain car le mouvement pacifiste se
mobilise à l'échelle internationale de
grandes manifestations d'opposition à la
gare du Vietnam sont organisés sur le
continent européen en Grande-Bretagne
des marches pour le désarmement
nucléaire ont lieu sans incident depuis
le début de la décennie mais en mars
1968 devant l'ambassade des États-Unis à
Londres les protestations dégénèrent en
violence après que les fleurs se sont
fanées il y a eu un rappel à la réalité
avec le constat que la fin de la guerre
au Vietnam était une cause qui soulevait
désormais les jeunes du monde entier le
Vietnam c'était la guerre froide hors de
tout contrôle des jeunes ils mourraient
plusieurs se demandaient pourquoi la
Grande-Bretagne bien qu'elle n'est pas
envoyée de troupes là-bas accorder tout
de même un soutien tacite aux États-Unis
dans la foule observant les
affrontements entre la police et les
manifestants se trouvent Mick Jagger
lui-même
son rôle au sein de la contre-culture
s'est transformé depuis son procès et il
prend maintenant sa place sur la ligne
de front
le rôle de Mick Jagger dans la
contre-culture est très intéressante
il ressentait d'une part ce désir
instinctif de réagir comme un mal appris
en faisant un doigt d'honneur mais il
avait aussi étudié à la langue d'une
scroll avec économique
il s'intéressait à certains des concepts
intellectuels qui sous-tendent les
différentes notions concernant
l'organisation de la société
on l'a vu à la télévision britannique
dans des débats avec Marco Madrid et
Merry White House deux personnages de
l'époque à l'attitude vraiment
réactionnaire
à la télévision et de débattre des
raisons pour lesquelles la société était
selon lui organisée en fonction de base
erronée c'était très alléchant pour
Jagger
ces idées se sont aussi infiltrés dans
ces textes de chansons
[Musique]
ce nouvel engagement du chanteur arrive
au moment parfait le climat de
confrontation en Europe s'intensifie
davantage en mai lorsque des émeutes
d'étudiants éclatent à Paris ce
mouvement de résistance c'est en
rapidement au travailleur les
manifestants appellent à la Révolution
et les rues de la France deviennent un
véritable champ de bataille en plein
milieu de cette tourmente sort le
nouveau 47 tours des Rolling Stones
Jumping Jack flash
émeutes de l'ambassade américaine
mais aussi celle de Berlin et de Paris
la jeunesse devenait une force
internationale en quelque sorte les
Stones quand ils ont retrouvé leur élan
et son retour né au redemment blues
musclé se sont révélés être un excellent
symbole de tout ça les bétons avaient
incarné tous les courants de 67 mais en
68 les Stones étaient mieux placés pour
refléter les les énergies plus sombres
qui se déployaient alors
[Musique]
les stands sont de retour
propulsés par un riff et par un message
de rébellion c'était
exactement ce que le moment semblait
réclamer
ça les heures lancées Jumping Jack flash
a tout enclenché avec je suis né dans un
ouragan de feu croisé et le reste des
images que les Stones employaient tous
ceux qui trouvaient que la vie était
devenue folle pouvait s'identifier à ça
il y avait le Vietnam mais il se passait
plein d'autres choses alors oui c'est
ouragan de feu croisé à rallumer la
flamme
[Musique]
les Rolling Stones émergent donc
revitalisées après une année difficile
mais aux États-Unis le paysage politique
est de nouveau ébranlé par la tragédie
en avril le leader du mouvement des
droits civiques Martin Luther King s'est
fait assassiner sa mort a provoqué des
émeutes dans plus de 110 villes la plus
grande vague d'agitation sociale que le
pays est connu depuis la guerre de
Sécession
malgré ses bouleversements une figure
politique offre encore de l'espoir frère
cadet du président John fennedy décédé
cinq ans plus tôt Robert Kennedy est
l'un des principaux candidats pour
succéder à Linden big Johnson au Parti
démocrate
défenseur de la justice sociale et des
droits de la personne cette opposant à
la guerre du Vietnam laissant revoir la
possibilité de changement depuis
l'intérieur du système politique
malheureusement le 5 juin 1968 peu après
avoir remporté l'élection primaire de
Californie
il est assassiné à son tour
il représentait effectivement l'espoir
même pour ceux qui n'avaient pas
nécessairement investi dans sa campagne
tous avec c’était le cas il s'agit d'un
véritable vol qui a eu un grand impact
sur la culture des jeunes
rien d'autre depuis ma naissance n'a
autant contribué à anéantir l'optimisme
que ces deux assassinats il s'agissait
en fait de deux assassinats dans
l'esprit de ceux d'entre nous qui sont
arrivés à l'âge adulte dans les années
60 il y avait eu Jean neuf Kennedy puis
King puis ensuite Barbie Kennedy ce sont
les trois événements les plus
les plus horrifiants de ma jeunesse
ce qui me frappe le plus quand je
repense à cette période c'est à quel
point la culture était saturée de
violence
l'idée de placer ses espoirs dans l'un
ou l'autre de ces personnages commencer
à sembler vaguement ridicule parce que
beaucoup d'entre eux se faisaient tuer
violemment sous nos yeux
pour la contre-culture l'idéal de paie
d'amour perd vite son attrait et
révolution devient le nouveau cri de
ralliement
beaucoup de ceux qui jusque là suivaient
le mouvement uniquement pour le sexe la
drogue et le rock n' roll commencent à
s'impliquer politiquement cette tendance
atteint son point culminant lors d'une
manifestation à la convention nationale
du parti démocratique en août 1968
la convention nationale du parti
démocrate à Chicago s'annonçait comme le
couronnement de you Burton free le
vice-président de Johnson et son
successeur désigné qui n’impressionnait
personne
une sorte de conseil national de hippie
non affiliée était déterminée à créer
une diversion une grève une
manifestation devant le siège de la
convention
ils ont appelé les jeunes de tout le
pays à descendre sur Chicago
la ville de Chicago était dirigée par un
dur à cuir du nom de Richard daily le
maire qui ne voyait pas pourquoi on
devait permettre à ces jeunes de faire
quoi que ce soit
des affrontements dans les rues à
l'extérieur de la Convention
des milliers de jeunes se sont fait
tabasser gazer et traîné en prison par
la police de Chicago qui agissait
finalement comme la police nazi dans les
années 30
[Musique]
les attaques policières lors de la
convention nationale du parti démocrate
à Chicago en 1968 en constitué une ligne
de démarcation qui a totalement
radicalisé la jeunesse le monde entier
nous regarde était un des champs des
manifestants à cette convention on avait
ce sentiment qu'il n'était pas possible
de détourner le regard une fois qu'on
avait vu ces images qu'on ne pouvait pas
ignorer ça et faire semblant de rien il
fallait choisir son camp
[Musique]
le tour du monde les Rolling Stones
lancent le 45 tours Street fighting man
inspiré par les émeutes de guarenusquare
plutôt cette année-là
déclarez subversive cette chanson est
immédiatement interdite par les stations
de radio de Chicago renforçant ainsi la
réputation du groupe auprès de la
contre-culture
les sentiments de l'époque tant aux
États-Unis qu'en Grande-Bretagne a
toujours eu cette capacité de saisir
l'air du temps c'était une de ses forces
en tant qu'auteur
[Musique]
le sang coulé dans les rues la
température augmentait très très vite
tout avait tellement changé en un an
dans l'univers en 1967 à Street fighting
Man en 1968
il faut savoir choisir son moment et le
fait que ce morceau soit sorti justement
là à placer les stands en plein cœur des
événements comme il ne l'avait
probablement pas été depuis plusieurs
années on ne peut pas nier que le sommet
absolu des Beatles a été Serge in
Peppers en 1967 même s'il ne faut pas
oublier que Hey Jude est sorti en 1968
les textes politiques les plus forts de
Daylon étaient déjà derrière lui en 1968
je dirais donc que les Rolling Stones
étaient sans doute à ce moment-là la
plus puissante force politique au sein
du monde du rock n'
rollingence des Rolling Stones se
confirme à la fin de l'année avec le
lancement de
lors d'une conférence de presse bien
arrosée c'est l'occasion de célébrer
pour Jagger riches et Bryan Jones qui
ont tout droit à éviter de justesse la
prison au cours de cette année difficile
la contre-culture dans son ensemble
n'est toutefois pas d'humeur aussi
festive à la suite de l'élection du
candidat républicain Richard Nixon comme
président des États-Unis en novembre
cette élection jette du sel sur les
blessures infligées en 1968 le nouvel
album des Rolling Stones et sa
remarquable première chanson Sympathy
for the devil démontre que le groupe n'a
rien perdu de sa pertinence et continue
de s'opposer à l'ordre établi tous ceux
qui avaient des doutes sur ce que les
Rolling Stones allaient faire après
inter satanic me justice ruquest en vue
ses doutes effacés par baggers bangwaite
dans le film qu'ils ont tourné avec
Jean-Luc Godard on assiste à
l'enregistrement de semper for the devil
on peut voir qu'au cours du tournage
Jagger a dû changer les paroles de j'ai
crié qui a tué Kennedy j'ai crié qui a
tué les Kennedy
[Musique]
quand on doit faire une révision comme
celle-là c'est qu'on évolue vraiment à
la limite de l'actualité
pour annoncer l'album bigles Bangkok il
n'aurait jamais pu trouver un morceau
plus percutant que celui-là
[Musique]
au plaisir qu'il prenait à jouer ce
personnage de seigneur de l'anarchie
[Musique]
comme Sympathy for the devil
il est à mon avis tomber amoureux de ce
rôle de seigneur de l'anarchie qui
apporte chaos et turbulences dans son
sillage
c'est très attrayant pour quelqu'un
comme lui mais c'est aussi plutôt
dangereux
alors que les Stones reprennent leur
place au premier rang des groupes
rebelles on assiste en Grande-Bretagne à
l'émergence d'une nouvelle scène
musicale qui s'est développée au cours
des deux années précédentes inspirée par
les groupes psychédéliques de San
Francisco ceux de l'un de grand
britannique ont eu aussi commencé à
expérimenter avec de nouveaux éclairages
et la longueur des chansons sur la scène
du yufo le principal club de ce milieu
Pink Floyd s'y fait connaître avant de
prendre la tête d'affiche en 1968 du
premier grand concert gratuit à
wrightpark à Londres produit par le
Black Hill Enterprise devant est-elle
succès les mêmes promoteurs organisent
un événement encore plus ambitieux avec
le super groupe blindfight en 1969 le
spectacle de Pink Floyd a fait école
parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de monde
mais c'était quand même un petit conseil
on en avait pas fait la promotion de
façon acharnée
le concert de blindfight lui a créé un
exemple parce que c'était un amalgame de
crime et de trafic
deux groupes extrêmement populaire
devant 150 000 spectateurs personne ne
s'est fait arrêter il n'y a pas eu de
bagarre c'est une belle journée très
bucolique et champêtre à l'anglaise
English
[Musique]
les Rolling Stones s'adressent donc à
Sam coatler pour organiser un grand
concert gratuit après leur succès
commercial de l'année précédente il
pense obtenir ainsi la reconnaissance de
la contrepulture et effectuer un retour
en force sur scène en mai le groupe a dû
se défaire de Brian Jones devenu trop
instable ce spectacle constituerait le
moment idéal pour présenter son nouveau
guitariste micellaire une date est fixée
en juillet
l'anticipation est grande mais deux
jours avant l'événement on apprend que
Brian Jones a été retrouvé mort dans sa
piscine
est mort quelques jours avant le
spectacle la question dans ce genre de
situation c'est bien entendu qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire
il y a dans le monde de la musique comme
dans toutes les entreprises théâtrales
ce dicton qui veut que le spectacle doit
continuer mais qui estimait que le
concert devait être présenté en mémoire
de Brian
[Musique]
au départ dans les groupies comme Pink
Floyd et taïwenn
ils avaient cessé de jouer après les
arrestations quelques années plus tôt
tant de choses s'étaient produite depuis
une fois sur scène ils ont libéré des
papillons qui sont morts rapidement ce
qui n'était pas vraiment de bonne augure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça a été un des pires concerts que j'ai
vu les Rolling Stones donnés il n'avait
pas assez répété
semblait ne pas savoir s'il ne faisait
que passer ou s'il allait rester jungle
dansait sur des papillons morts ce qui
était probablement la chose la plus
tristement comique que j'ai jamais vu
j'étais si triste c'est dommage qu'il se
soit senti obligé de faire ça
malgré la déplorable prestation des
Rolling Stones le concert est un
événement majeur réunissant plus d'un
quart de millions de personnes qui ne
semblent pas vraiment consciente des
lacunes du groupe sur scène l'ambiance
communautaire de l'événement fait écho à
l'unité paisible caractéristique des
happenings de San Francisco qu'ils l'ont
inspiré d'ailleurs tout comme à ses
fameuses spectacles du parc du Golden
Gate la sécurité assurée par les liens
[Musique]
de façon impeccable personne ne dit se
rendre à l'hôpital personne n'était
poignardée ni abattu rien de tout ça ces
gala conduisaient des motos BSA 125 qui
était tout juste plus puissant qu'un
scooter
[Musique]
n'était pas vraiment comme ceux de la
Californie
il dessinait leur couleur à la craie sur
leur blouson cuir
on les a vu servant le thé derrière la
scène du concert de highpark
si c'est l'idée que les Rolling Stones
se faisaient des anges ils allaient
avoir droit à une surprise assez
radicale
les Rolling Stones se trouveront bientôt
face à face avec les véritables
en effet après le concert de right Park
le groupe prépare une nouvelle tournée
pour renflouer ses coffres car les
membres du groupe n'ont plus un sou
malgré leur récent regain de popularité
en 1965 leur producteur Angelo a fait
entrer le comptable
new-yorkaisons ce négociateur coriace a
très vite démontré sa valeur pour le
groupe en lui obtenant de meilleurs
contrats ayant rejeté les parts en 1968
il devient alors seule responsable de la
gestion et c'est là que commence les
problèmes pour les Stones sa compagnie
ako a un contrôle total sur les affaires
financières et les comptes bancaires du
groupe et il s'avère de plus en plus
difficile d'obtenir de klines qu'il
débloque des fonds
ils avaient beau être un groupe
mondialement connu il mourrait
pratiquement de faim et n'avait pas
d'autre choix que de faire une tournée
aux États-Unis il savait bien que si
Alain Klein était impliqué dans son
organisation c'est lui qui emporterait
la part du lion des recettes eux ils
feraient une énorme tournée sans
recevoir d'argent ils ont donc réussi je
ne sais trop comment à convaincre le
neveu d'alunich a quitté la compagnie de
son oncle à Cox et à travailler
directement pour eux afin de mettre sur
pied cette tourbe en nous j'ai quitté
l'entreprise de mon oncle quelques
semaines plus tard j'ai reçu un appel de
Mick Jagger il voulait que j'organise
cette tournée je l'ai souligné que
j'avais quitté ABCO il m'a répondu qu'il
le savait déjà je lui ai donc dit de
demander permission à mon oncle parce
que je ne voulais pas que ça me cause de
problème dans la famille il m'a assuré
qu'il le ferait selon ce que m'a dit Sam
coatler lors de notre première
conversation les stands ont plutôt fait
venir mon oncle au Royaume-Uni peu de
temps après pour le renvoyer
en revoyant Klein le groupe voit du coup
ses actifs gelés la série de concerts
aux États-Unis est donc encore plus
cruciale pour sa survie financière
alors que les préparatifs de la tournée
sont en cours une figure majeure de la
scène musicale de la côte ouest
américaine arrive à Londres ce promoteur
vient semer les graines du concert
gratuit à aldement
l'un des gérants
le directeur des disques epic un gars du
nom de Chelsea
celui-ci était aussi bons amis avec qui
et mec mais lesquels les a présenté à
Rock scaling
c'est essentiellement mis à leur santé
les louanges des concerts gratuits
c'était si merveilleux ce qui se passait
à San Francisco
convoquait
lui a dit vous venez aux États-Unis il
faut que vous donniez un concert gratuit
au parc du Golden Gate je sais
exactement quoi faire je peux arranger
tout ça cela dit ils ont aussi parlé de
la possibilité pour les stance de jouer
au Taj Mahal et de toutes sortes
d'autres idées folles rock est parti de
là sans vraiment se rendre compte qu'il
venait de proposer au Rolling Stones de
leur organiser un concert à San
Francisco mais quitte lui s'en est
souvenu
la perspective d’être la tête d'affiche
d'un concert gratuit dans ce bastion de
la contre-culture se fait de plus en
plus attrayante pour les Rolling Stones
à la Miu le festival de Woodstock réunit
32 groupes et chanteurs et un auditoire
de près de 1/2 millions de personnes
pendant 3 jours pour devenir l'un des
événements culturels les plus marquants
de l'époque malgré les difficultés de
l'année précédente et l'élection de
Richard Nixon ce festival paisible et
harmonieux démontre que la
contre-culture est bel et bien unie et
florissante
la contre-culture se portait très bien
en 1969
[Musique]
constitue en quelque sorte son point
culminant
[Musique]
cette année-là on pensait vraiment qu'on
était en train de gagner que le
mouvement était en pleine croissance et
qu'il constituait une force implacable
il ne fait aucun doute que je croyais
tout ça ou si naïve que ça puisse
paraître aujourd'hui
cela dit cette opinion était largement
répandue à savoir qu'on allait changer
le monde
on y a vraiment cru
et en 1969 on était convaincu que rien
ne pouvait nous arrêter
octobre 1969 l'équipe des Rolling Stones
arrive à Los Angeles pour les derniers
préparatifs de la tournée une quinzaine
d'arrêts sont prévues à l'itinéraire
mais il n'est toujours pas question de
concert gratuit
de 7 novembre à l'Université d'État du
Colorado le groupe monte pour la
première fois en trois ans sur une scène
américaine
malheureusement comme hijd Park le
groupe est encore rouillé
le premier spectacle a démontré à quel
point ils étaient mal préparés pour leur
tourner
juste avant le concert on m'a demandé de
lui présenter je n'ai même pas pensé à
ce que j'allais dire mais une minute
avant le début du concert je me suis
précipité sur scène et j'ai lancé
voici le plus grand groupe de rock n'
roll au monde les Rolling Stones tout le
monde applaudit le groupe est entré en
scène à la fin du spectacle mais qui est
passé devant moi en sortant de série m'a
dit je veux te parler
il n'y avait pas l'air très heureux on
est allés dans la loge seul tous les
deux il m'a regardé il m'a dit ne nous
appelle pas le meilleur groupe de rock
n' roll au monde
c'est gênant c'est à quoi j'ai répondu
et bien soit vous l'êtes soit vous ne
l'êtes pas ils sont immédiatement
retournés en répétition ils ont loué le
studio où on achève bien les chevaux
étaient filmés sur le terrain de Warner
Brothers
suivant les Rolling Stones prouvent
qu'ils sont effectivement le plus grand
groupe de rock n' roll au monde
en se déplaçant vers l'est de Los
Angeles au Texas et de l'Alabama New
York il s'améliore à chaque concert
aux côtés de l'auteur Stanley boost l'un
des proches du groupe le journaliste
Michael LED d'une New York Times
assistant personne à la remarquable
ascension du groupe
[Musique]
j’étais intégré dans l'équipe de tournée
je n'ai jamais payé pour l'hôtel ni pour
un billet d'avion je faisais simplement
partie de leur entourage comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer c'était une
affectation en or pour moi c'était assez
génial
Stanley moi on se regardait parfois l'un
l'autre pendant que les Stones étaient
sur scène et nous derrière les amplis on
s'échangeait un regard lui et moi quand
on prenait conscience du fait qu'on
vivait ce dont tous les hippies du monde
ne faisaient que rêver accompagner les
Rolling Stones entouré on s'est bien
éclaté ils étaient en pleine forme et
ils ont traversé le pays en s'améliore
en chaque fois un peu plus
en 1969 les stands étaient incroyables
leurs prestations étaient tout
simplement magistrales je me souviens
quand l'éclairage de la salle s'est
éteint et qu'on ne voyait plus que les
lumières rouges de leurs amplificateurs
dans le noir au Madison Square Garden
j'ai pensé mon Dieu dans quelques
secondes les Rolling Stones vont jouer
juste ici je me souviens à quel point
c'était excitant
et ils ont été excellents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu les Stones au Forum de Los
Angeles lors de cette tournée
j'avais des billets pour le deuxième
spectacle qui devait commencer à 23
heures il a plutôt commencé à 2h du
matin les stands sont entrés en scène
vers les quatre heures et ils ont donné
ce qui était le meilleur concert de rock
n' roll que j'avais jamais vu jusque là
encore aujourd'hui 50 ans plus tard ça
compte parmi les plus grands spectacles
de rock n' roll de ma vie
ils étaient incroyables
pendant que les Rolling Stones conquiert
un auditoire après l'autre en coulisses
il commence à élaborer des plans pour un
concert gratuit sur la côte ouest
[Musique]
il a renoncé la balle concernant ce qui
s'était dit à Londres comme quoi ce
serait génial que les stands donnent un
concert gratuit avec les Green
l'idée a fait son chemin peu à peu un
moment donné les Stones ont décidé
d'envoyer quelqu'un en Californie pour
rencontrer les gens de greatford Ed et y
voir sérieusement si tout était possible
c'est moi qui sont choisis pour y aller
au départ l'idée de rockscally était
d'obtenir un permis pour un concert de
Jefferson Airplane et des greatford Dead
puis d'annoncer 24 heures avant le
spectacle la participation d'un invité
spécial
ils ont discuté de la possibilité que
les hairs Angels forment une escort pour
accompagner les Stones de l'aéroport au
concert c'était ça l'idée ça aurait pu
être fantastique les Rolling Stones vous
voyez
les responsables des stratégies
commerciales pour les stands
ont commencé à se dire qu'il pourrait
s'agir d'une occasion très lucrative
assez rapidement l'équipe de gestion des
Rolling Stones dans ce cas-ci ronishnder
et un type étrange du nom de John James
qui avait réussi à s'infiltrer dans leur
cercle a décidé de se charger de cette
affaire on va s'en occuper ils ont pris
contact avec le maire de San Francisco
ce qui n'était pas vraiment une bonne
idée ça a tué toute possibilité
d'organiser ce concert à San Francisco
en demandant directement des permis pour
un concert au Parc du Golden Gate
l’équipe des Rolling Stones fait sonner
la larme au bureau du maire le camp des
greatford Dead a prévu un événement de
moindre importance avec des accords
conclus en coulisses l'idée que 300000
admirateurs des Rolling Stones
descendront sur une ville mal équipée
pour un tel festival effraie les
autorités ils mettent immédiatement
terme au projet il faut donc trouver un
nouvel emplacement et le temps commence
à manquer alors qu'on explore les
possibilités l'implication des hairs
Angels s'officialise
pour surveiller les générateurs comme il
n'y avait pas d'électricité à cet
endroit il fallait louer de gros
générateurs afin d'en produire
suffisamment pour alimenter les
équipements de sang d'éclairage etc je
suis allé rencontrer les anges ce sont
tes forcés de m'expliquer qu'ils
n'étaient pas des flics ils allaient
être heureux de rester assis à côté des
générateurs pour empêcher le public d'y
toucher sans plus parce qu'ils aimaient
la musique aussi
au départ était qu'il placerait leur
moto devant la scène la beauté de la
chose était que personne n'oserait se
précipiter vers la scène en théorie du
moins
pendant que ces plans se concrétisent
les Rolling Stones engagent les frères
Albert et David mezos de réalisateurs de
documentaires renommés pour suivre la
tournée et filmer les spectacles du Mas
de ce mousquare Garden et le conseil
gratuit qui doit suivre lors de son
passage à New York le groupe effectue un
retour à l'émission où il a six
fameusement choqué l'Amérique en 1974
les Rolling Stones semblent avoir bouclé
la boucle et comme porte-parole de leur
génération ils sont plus pertinents que
jamais ils sont passés au headshow 5 ans
après leur premier apparition à
l'émission et quelle différence ça
faisait ils y ont joué Gimme Shelter une
chanson qui symbolisait parfaitement
tant de choses qui se passaient à
l'époque le tumulte dans la société il
rejoignait énormément de monde car si à
la fois un groupe de pop et un groupe de
rock ils ont chanté Gimme Shelter une
chanson très subversive sombre et pleine
de rage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Ant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le viol le meurtre ce n'est qu'un coup
de feu de distance qu'est-ce qui nous
attend on arrive à la fin de la décennie
la situation est assez lugubre sur le
plan social musicalement les Stones
étaient probablement en train
d'atteindre un nouveau sommeil avait-il
déjà fait une meilleure chanson que
Gimme Shelter je n'en suis pas convaincu
c'est un morceau incroyable ce n'est pas
de la musique pop telle qu'on la connaît
c'est les Stones au sommet de leur art
le 28 novembre fort des acclamations de
la critique pour leur concert et
conscient que leur tournée capte
l'attention de toute la presse
américaine les Rolling Stones tiennent
une conférence de presse pour annoncer
publiquement leurs concerts gratuits à
aldement
il ne s'agira pas seulement de concert
des Stones les plus grands noms de la
scène musicale de la côte ouest figurent
aussi au programme comme les greatford
dead Jeffers
national l'emplacement du concert n'est
toutefois pas encore confirmé le circuit
de course de searspoint qui appartient à
un homme d'affaires nommé dix injon
semble alors le choix le plus probable
on m'a demandé d'aller négocier une
entente pour le circuit de course de
searspoint j'ai donc pris l'avion pour
San Francisco je me suis assis avec
dexandre et il m'a essentiellement dit
et bien pour votre cancer gratuit il
nous faut 100000 dollars pour tout
nettoyer et 100000 dollars de plus pour
une couverture d'assurance de 10
millions il voulait aussi 100000 dollars
de plus pour une autre raison et vous
nous cédez les droits du film j'ai
répondu tout d'abord c'est un concert
gratuit on ne va pas vous payer 300 000
dollars
il ne reste plus que deux jours avant le
concert et l'équipe des Rolling Stones
est désespérée un nouvel emplacement est
proposé une extrémiste le circuit de
course altamante a une centaine de
kilomètres à l'est de San Francisco
situé au milieu d'une zone tranquille du
côté de la médaille
de l'ancien pilote de course des Carter
ce n'est pas un lieu très propice à un
grand festival de rock
le circuit de course
et c'était pour un derby de démolition
c'était le jeudi après-midi et les gens
des Stones ne savaient pas exactement
quoi faire mais il devait bien aller
jeter un coup d'oeil ils sont donc
montés dans un hélicoptère de la
circulation fournie par une station de
radio locale en emmenant rock Scully et
Michael Lang l'organisateur de Woodstock
qui est apparu là pour une raison
quelconque il s'envole vers altamante
taché d'huile du verre brisé partout
bref un horrible panorama et se demande
c'est quoi ce bordel mais il entend
Michael
c'est parfait on peut faire ça ici
le concert aura donc lieu à Adamante
avec seulement une journée pour préparer
le site l'équipe de tournée s'empresse
de tout mettre en place
une bonne partie de ce travail ayant
déjà été effectuée à searspoint on
démonte tout simplement la scène et la
grille éclairage pour les remonter à
aldemont
malheureusement le temps manque pour
repenser ou modifier les plans originaux
et à son arrivée le directeur de Tournai
trouve plusieurs raisons de s'inquiéter
[Musique]
le problème le plus sérieux c'était la
seule
elle aurait été parfaite pour siège sur
le flanc d'une colline mais là il
fallait la placer au bas d'une colline
et elle atteignait à peine la hauteur
des genoux il allait donc être très
facile pour les spectateurs de monter
dessus sans aucun effort le spectacle
allait avoir lieu le samedi j'ai vu
l'endroit le vendredi midi pour la
première fois j'étais horrifié il y
avait déjà près de 100.000 personnes sur
le site et cette scène était isolée au
milieu de tous ces gens vous voyez
on a donc essayé de créer des barricades
avec des camions et en plaçant des trucs
tout autour afin de pouvoir préparer le
spectacle mais je t'ai conscient de le
vendredis qu'on allait avoir un énorme
problème d'ordre public
le spectacle aura quand même lieu sans
approvisionnement en nourriture ou en
nous et sans commodité d'aucune sorte
seul les services médicaux de base sont
assurés sur les sites les 300 000
spectateurs qui affluent vers le circuit
de course altomont n'ont aucune idée de
ce qui les attend c'est la toute fin des
années 60 le dernier rassemblement de
masse de contre-culture avant le début
d'une nouvelle décennie ce qui devrait
être l'occasion d'une grande célébration
le soleil s'est levé sur un jour gris à
un moment donné ils ont officiellement
laissé entré le public et cette foule de
jeunes s'est précipitée vers le bas de
la colline avec leur couverture pour
arriver à s'approprier une toute petite
place sous un soir l'ambiance était très
agréable enjoué on avait vraiment
l'impression que ça allait être comme à
Woodstock c'est génial je n'ai pas pu me
rendre à Woodstock mais je suis là
l'ambiance ne tarde toutefois pas à
changer
le problème c'est qu'il y avait beaucoup
de LSD de mauvais acides de mauvaise
drogues et d'alcool bon marché le
spectacle a commencé à peine de samedi à
midi mais il y avait déjà 300 ou 400000
personnes complètement défoncées les
bagarres ont débuté mais ça n'a fait que
dégénérer en Suisse
avec la présence visible des hazenjoes
autour de la scène et dans toute
l'enceinte du festival le premier groupe
sintana commence à jouer à midi
il n'a pas encore terminé sa prestation
quand le militant pacifiste alexson
devient la première des nombreuses
victimes de l'agressivité brutale des
gens engagés pour assurer la sécurité du
concert
un latino obèse est complètement nue
défoncé au LSD probablement mélangé avec
de la mettedrine et qui buvait du vin
bon marché à grande gorgée
a descendu la colline jusqu'à l'avant de
la scène où se trouvait les hairs Angels
ça commence mal
qui a vu ce qui se passait à sauté au
sol pour se lancer dans son discours
comme quoi nous sommes tous des frères
en suppliant les hairs Angels de ne pas
tabasser ce gars là ils se sont donc
retournés contre Burt ils ont fait
pleuvoir des queues de billard sur lui
ils l'ont tellement amoché qui lui a
fallu 60 points de suture sur la tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était effrayant je dirais même que
c'était rationnellement effrayant car on
a inventé rien
des actes d'une grande laideur de
malfaisance et de sauvagerie ce sont
déroulés sous nos yeux
et ça nous semblait encore pire parce
que un mythe c'était construit pendant
la décennie précédente comme quoi ils
étaient très cool
il est très important de comprendre que
la section de San Francisco des anges
était basé dans le quartier
fréquemment dans les coulisses des
concerts des greatford Dead et de
Jefferson Airplane ils accompagnaient
les équipes de tournées en moto c'est un
groupe de Elsa entièrement différent de
celui de la maison mère à Oakland par
exemple
de prendre les problèmes qui sont
survenus sur le site du concert à
Altamont
ce sont tous produits devant la scène
et ont presque entièrement été causés
par des membres de la section de San
rosé des
angelsi était totalement différente
c'est à une heure de San Francisco ce
n'était pas des hippies il n'avaient pas
l'habitude d'aller au fil mort il ne
fréquentait pas les coulisses des
concerts c'était de véritables bruits de
californiennes à l'ancienne et c'était
eux devant la scène avec les queues de
billard
[Musique]
il reste du Rolling Stones sont arrivés
sauf bellouamine mais au moment où mec
descendait de l'hélicoptère un jeune
homme dérangé qui avait pris de l'acide
il a donné un coup de poing
[Musique]
c'était donc assez effrayant
mais qui est arrivé et plusieurs sont
venus lui rapporter à quel point la
situation a été horrible
comme on était installé dans une petite
caravane on a sûrement entendu quelques
histoires sur la violence qui sévissait
mais on a rien vu et on ne savait pas ce
qui se passait cela dit on ressentait
bien je ne sais pas si c'était comme ça
dans d'autres situations mais on le
sentait dans l'air
cette ambiance sinistre suffit à
convaincre les greatfield dead
d'abandonner tout simplement le mini
festival arrivé peu après les Rolling
Stones ils apprennent que des membres de
leur équipe de tournée ont été agressés
par les herzanjoes et décide de repartir
le groupe qui allume à une piloter ce
projet de concert gratuit et recommandé
l'embauche des Angeles ne veut plus
participer à l'événement
au bout du compte les greats ont fui ils
se sont retirés ils ont vu qu'il y avait
trop de violence s'ils avaient joué je
pense que ça aurait été une toute autre
histoire on ne dirait pas ce sont les
Stones si les greatford dead avaient
joué pendant deux ou trois heures comme
à leur habitude ça aurait calmé tout le
monde ça aurait pu finir par endormir
tout le monde avec toutes les drogues
qu'il prenaient mais ce qui compte
finalement c'est qu'ils se sont barrés
il y a donc eu un long délai avant que
les stands entrent en scène avec toutes
les mauvaises drogues qui circulaient la
violence et tout le reste mais les
stands ont quand même donné leur concert
ils n'ont pas fui
après le départ des greatford Dead
Crosby Stills national donne un concert
aussi bref que possible pendant que les
hazels continuent de frapper des
spectateurs
après une demi-heure à peine le groupe
sort rapidement de scène et des camps
immédiatement
il ne reste plus que les Rolling Stones
au programme mais leur prestations qui
devaient suivre ces greatford dead n'est
pas censé débuter avant plusieurs heures
la foule était assise là à attendre
ces gens étaient là depuis le début de
la journée il n'y avait pas d'eau pas de
toilette pas de nourriture
ils étaient coincés ange contre hanche
et Paul contre épaules et ils sont
restés là pendant plus deux heures sans
qu'il se passe quoi que ce soit
juste au moment où le soleil allait se
coucher Sony
sont arrivés après s'être réunies cet
après-midi là ils ont littéralement
traversé la foule jusqu'à l'avant de la
scène puis sont descendus de leur moto
et sont montés sur la scène comme
déploiement c'est impressionnant
toi l'obscurité tombée les Rolling
Stones entre
fit dépassé en nombre par les hordes de
motards tout autour d'eux il réagissent
malgré tout à surmonter cette atmosphère
troublante en se lançant dans leur
prestations
[Musique]
ont joué en se donnant complètement
probablement sous l'effet de la peur
parce qu'à ce moment-là les Hells and
Jones étaient partout sur la scène
si les Stones avaient arrêté de jouer il
n'en serait peut-être même pas sorti
vivant sous la contrainte et avec
l'adrénaline qui coulait à flot ils ont
donné une performance d'enfer
[Musique]
c'était tout simplement phénoménal
Charlie Watts
avec une précision incroyable les
guitares faisaient des étincelles et
Jagger chantait avec énormément de
convictions ce n'était pas à caricatural
ni loufoque comme il a parfois tendance
à le faire c'était vraiment sincère
cette performance impressionnante ne
suffit pas à mettre un terme à la
violence qui va bientôt interrompre leur
prestation plus tard certains membres du
groupe affirmeront qu'ils étaient
incapables de percevoir l'étendue des
actes de brutalité les caméras qui
filment les événements sur scène et
alentours elles montrent un concert qui
sombre dans le chaos
les choses allaient de mal empire la
situation était hors de contrôle des
bagages un peu partout des gens qui se
précipitaient sur la scène et qui s'en
faisait rejeter des échauffourés juste
devant la scène on était totalement
conscient de ce qui se passait tous
l'éclairage venait de l'arrière de la
scène 50000 watts d'éclairage dirigés
vers le public c'était aussi éclairé que
votre salon cette histoire que les
Rolling Stones ne savaient pas ce qui se
passait et qu'ils n'ont rien vu c'est de
la foutaise totale dans le film il y a
un moment Jagger danse mais ses yeux se
promènent dans l'auditoire il voit
quelqu'un prendre un coup de queue de
billard et taf il arrête de danser
a tellement de contrôle sur son public
le voir se débattre ainsi s'est
terrifiant
everyone
il ne fait aucun doute que les groupes
comme jeffersonor plane et le Rolling
Stones était devenu des avatars c'était
des dieux les voir désespérément essayer
de mettre fin à cette violence qui se
déroule sous leurs yeux et échoué
ça ne s'oublie pas
c'était gravé sur les visages des gens
devant la scène qui regardaient Jagger
et semblait dire je t'en prie arrête de
chanter et aide-nous c'est la mort tout
autour de nous
entre les chansons il y avait des
silences de morts et une sorte de
crac-crac le son de crâne se faisant
fendre des gens criaient non en espérant
que ça s'arrête le truc de la fraternité
humaine qui était le rêve des hippies
tout ça était vraiment en train de
s'effondrer complètement
j'étais juste derrière les amplis alors
je voyais seulement ce que ma position
me permettait de voir
à un moment donné Kings comme mardi
Barlin s'est arrêté et a dit et vous
pouvez pas faire ça ici et la musique
s'est arrêtée
[Musique]
une autre de ses attaques et c'était
tout simplement épouvantable
les gens étaient ils ressemblait à des
poissons dans un bol quand on y laisse
tomber un caillou tous les poissons des
guerpices aussi vite que possible
c'était le centre de quelque chose de
vraiment horrible et les spectateurs
essayaient simplement de s'enfuir aussi
vite qu'il le pouvait
donc
je suis parti j'ai quitté la scène et je
me suis éloigné en gravissant cette
petite colline puis j'ai compris que je
ne viendrai plus à ce genre d'événement
que je ne croirais plus au mix de
Woodstock de monture hip-hop du human
bein le choix des a été une erreur
monumentale
on n'est pas tous ce frère et sœur il y
a des éléments de laideur de méchanceté
et de cruauté en nous
qui sont trop puissants pour ça
cette violence effrénée culminera par un
homicide
un jeune étudiant de 18 ans mérite
Hunter ou quelles sont son prix les
hands and Jones un peu plus tôt quand il
a bondit sur un haut-parleur fait
l'erreur de revenir avec une arme à feu
il ne verra pas la fin du concert
finalement alors qu'il jouait un de ma
femme
attiré deux coups de feu à une vingtaine
de mètres de la Seine a été poignardée à
mort par un DS
de groupe arrêtez de jouer
soudain quelqu'un m'a dit run on a
besoin de l'ambulance un type s'est fait
poignarder j'ai commencé à courir vers
l'ambulance sur le côté de la scène mais
le chauffeur n'était pas là la situation
typique
j'ai crié pour trouver le chauffeur en
courant le long de la Seine où elle
chauffeur de l'ambulance et un flic m'a
dit attends un peu c'est pour le gars
qui a été poignardé j'ai répondu que oui
tu n'as pas besoin de courir il est mort
ça m'a donné comme un coup de poing au
ventre je me suis senti très mal à ce
moment là
bien que les frères maison aient choisi
de ne pas montrer ces images dans leur
documentaire Gimme Shelter des témoins
oculaires apporteront par la suite que
des membres du public ont porté le corps
de meresit Hunter jusqu'à la scène pour
tenter de mettre fin aux actes de
violence et alzhengers
qui ont porté son corps jusqu'à la scène
et j'ai parlé à celui qui l'a ensuite
porté derrière la scène
ils l'ont déposé sur la scène juste
devant kit Witcher
mais les anges se sont précipités pour
le repousser au sol il y a une photo de
ça il y a une photo de Mick Jagger qui
regarde vers le bas avec une main sur le
visage et une bande de hels Angeles
penchée mystérieusement dans le coin
il vient de déposer un cadavre sur votre
scène et ces gars le repousse qu'est-ce
que vous allez faire et bien ils vont
rester sur scène pendant encore une
heure
terrifié
il faut que tu sortes de scène tout de
suite d'accord il avait une arme il faut
que tu quittes la scène c'est à quoi mec
a répondu et je la félicite car je l'ai
toujours admiré pour ça
on ne peut pas sortir de scènes on ne
peut pas partir on doit finir le concert
quand les Rolling Stones m'ont enfin
dans un hélicoptère pour quitter
altamment ils sont sous le choc leur
emploi du temps chargé qui les oblige à
s'envoler dès le lendemain pour une
série de concerts en Europe ne leur
donne pas la chance de saisir pleinement
l'ampleur des événements qui viennent de
vivre dans les jours qui suivent et même
si certains reportages accorde peu
d'importance aux actes de violence
perpétrées au festival les faits
commence lentement à émerger
parallèlement à l'arrestation de
transmenson et de certains de ses
disciples meurtriers quelques jours
auparavant la tragédie d'altomante évite
reconnue comme un événement d'une réelle
importance historique
est toujours cité comme l'événement
ayant mis fin à l'époque du flow up
Power a l'air hippie
c'est assurément un jalon important
ça n'a fait que se détériorer après ce
moment-là
[Musique]
le meurtre a tendance à focaliser un peu
les esprits
d'après moi les Rolling Stones n'ont
compris l'importance ou l'impact
d'attente que longtemps après comme la
plupart d'entre nous
il y a cette célèbre anecdote au sujet
de Joe and live à qui on avait demandé
en 1950 quel impact la Révolution
française avait eu sur le cours de
l'histoire
il a répondu qu'il était trop tôt pour
le dire
ottomante en est donc une sorte
d'équivalent dans le monde du rock n'
roll
personne ne savait en décembre 69 ou
même à l'été de 1970 que se conserve à
l'entrée dans l'histoire du rock comme
un moment phare
un tournant un point de rupture
les dures vérités que ces événements
représentent
concerne la difficulté d'apporter des
changements profonds
ainsi que la place de la violence dans
la culture américaine
et le fait qu'elle se manifeste parfois
dans des contextes où on ne
s'imaginerait jamais qu'elle pourrait se
produire
[Musique]
ce sont des leçons importantes qui nous
ont signalé qu'il n'y aurait pas de
retour au jardin
c'est devenu assez évident en ce moment
là
je ne crois pas qu'il y avait beaucoup
de gens qui se promenaient encore avec
des fleurs dans les cheveux après ça
un nouvel équilibre s'est installé et
très rapidement en fait
le monde se demandait presque ce qui
s'était passé à la fin des années 60 ce
qui s'était vraiment passé le négatif
l'a emporté sur le positif
malheureusement et les gens ont voulu se
distancier de cette époque il y a donc
eu une rupture marquée dans les années
70 le truc des fleurs était devenu
complètement risible j'ai vu le
documentaire Montory pop en 1975 et
Élodie toi Riet il riait des vêtements
du son de tout ça m'a horrifié moi je
restais accroché au bon côté des années
60 mais pour les autres c'était mort et
enterré
les gens ne voulaient plus rien savoir
de cette période
c'est très vite devenu une époque
oubliée
et je crois qu'à les meurtres de Charles
Manson ont vraiment contribué à fermer
cette porte
bien que la carrière des Rolling Stones
se soit poursuivie jusqu'à nos jours ces
événements marquent aussi la fin d'une
époque pour eux les mauvais garçons de
l'invasion britannique n'occuperont plus
jamais un rôle central dans la culture
populaire la politique et les
commentaires sociaux seront notablement
absents de leurs œuvres ultérieures le
remarquable règne en tant que voie d'une
génération se termine donc ainsi il y a
les Rolling Stones avant altamante et
les Rolling Stones après altamons ce
sont deux choses distinctes toutes ces
histoires comme quoi il s'agissait de
mauvais garçon la sympathie pour le
diable et tout ça ça ne tenait plus
devant cet exemple absolument réel du
mal
après avoir vécu ça il n'allait jamais
pouvoir retourner dans leur petit
royaume imaginaire
[Musique]
ça se ressent dans l'album Sticky
Fingers les trois chansons enregistrées
pour cet album avant altamante soit
Brown Suger Warders move sont de type de
musique complètement différent des
autres ce qui est arrivé au Rolling
Stones
leur musique n'a jamais été la même leur
concerne n'ont jamais été les mêmes leur
relation interpersonnelle n'ont jamais
été les mêmes rien dans leur vie ne
s'est poursuivi comme avant
[Musique]